for children who haven't been vaccinated  there is a real danger a danger of being  ostracized of being made to feel  unwanted but here at Kind Hearts daycare  we've created a safe environment for all  children vaccinated and unvaccinated go  together as complete equals we provide a  safe non-judgmental environment where  all children can enjoy a carefree  existence without ever being made to  feel different just because they're at  risk of contracting and spreading deadly  and previously eradicated diseases and  in the event of danger Reinhardt's has  procedures in place to keep your  beautiful children safe with minimal  disruption  thank you  [Applause]  good idea  you